amenaza tormenta de nuevo en el estrecho
de formosa con el acuerdo entre eeuu y
taiwán de empezar las conversaciones
para fortalecer sus vínculos económicos
esas negociaciones a las que se opone
china tratarán sobre varios asuntos y un
par de ellos aluden directamente a pekín
de la coerción económica
es decir las sanciones que suelen poner
china a los países que tratan con taiwán
vuelve la distorsión que causan las
empresas públicas fuertemente
subvencionadas en el comercio
internacional esas conversaciones son la
compensación a la ausencia de taiwán en
el tratado económico del indo pacífico
es la apuesta más fuerte de eeuu para
contrarrestar la influencia china en la
región
eeuu no incluyo a taiwán para no irritar
a pekín pero el clima ha cambiado no
parece ya que para eeuu sea una
prioridad mantener unas relaciones
bilaterales saludables con china y
ninguna línea roja parece ahora a salvo
ni siquiera un posible tratado de libre
comercio que taipei le ha pedido a
washington durante muchos años y que es
hasta ahora por prudencia había
rechazado taiwán apenas cuenta con 23
millones de habitantes pero es el octavo
socio comercial de eeuu y su relevancia
es fundamental porque es la primera
potencia mundial en la fabricación de
chips y semiconductores de última
generación